excellent right thank you very much for
coming along so as introduced my name is
Colin glas I'm one of the co-founders of
jumping Rivers a a few years ago I got
roped into writing a book H the way that
happens is Publishers say you can write
a book and you've got 18 months and you
go yeah I'll do that CU in 18 months
time I have lots of time 18 months comes
around flipping quickly uh jumping
Rivers clearly the name tells you about
us but just in case it doesn't uh we do
lots of data science all the data
science stuff you think of you know are
python shiny apps we do lots of machine
learning manage posit Services come and
have a chat uh uh around by the
exhibitors we've got a stall there
right what are we talking about so we're
talking about git so if you've used git
I'm sure you've all used git before
you've got that tortured look in your
face H so if you've used G you've
probably came across this book right so
Jenny was in the last talk she's popular
writes excellent packages she also
writes excellent books so if you've not
seen this book have a look it tells you
how to be happy with get and GI
Hub I suppose we could all go home now
couldn't we cuz well if if Jenny says
it's true
and not to go against Jenny but I
sometimes get things like this you know
detached head does anyone actually know
what detached head means right even
though the message is very clear you're
in detached what and so we've got this
and then get thinks well you're mocking
me so now we're just going to reject you
H you're just not getting to push so
it's like doesn't seem to be in a very
happy place so clearly we're doing it
wrong because that's always the issue
isn't it you know if we're doing it
wrong you talk to someone who knows get
it's like ah you're doing it wrong
uh and so it's probably a get workflow
okay so you know we've got the wrong
sort of workflow which is why we're
getting rejected and and why we've got
detached head whatever that may mean uh
so you might think well let's think
about a workflow this came from an
actual stack Overflow question so I'm
not just making this up so it must be
correct so you might have the main
branch right so these little orange dots
are your commit messages okay so you
know you go along you add little commits
you can even imagine a little happy face
in each of these little commits because
we're good but we're going along and
then well
every so often we have a bug in a code
not me obviously other people have bugs
in a code but we might have a little bug
in a code and so we we need we we do
some bugs there's going to be a type on
the next slide it's guaranteed H we'll
have a lot bug in the code and that's
fine it's not too complicated you know
that's I think that's okay we can deal
with that yeah but then we really need a
Dev Branch because we're proper software
developers so we want a nice Dev Branch
because you know that that feels good
and we've probably got some sort of
release Branch as well because we're
really doing it properly so now we've
got a release branch that tells us when
things are released and we've got a Dev
Branch because that's showing how we're
updating and we've got these hot fixes
and that's okay and then someone comes
along goes but we want to add another
feature it's okay we've got another
feature and we're working in another
team so we've now got another feature
branch and it just gets absolutely
chaotic and I'm not making this up I
took this picture from a stack Overflow
question saying this is our workflow is
does this sound sensible and the answer
was yes that looks really
good and so I know what you're thinking
right I can look around and I can see it
in your face I know what you're thinking
cuz I thought the same right I really
did can we trust Jenny Bryan when it
comes down
to is Jenny in the room please
no uh can we trust Jenny so this talk is
now going to be about this can we trust
Jenny Brian talk right so so let's take
this
through so I'm going to ask you a very
personal question and I'm not not
expecting an answer to yourself keep it
inside how important is your
code are you on the left and if we're
honest with yourself no one really cares
maybe not even yourself and that's a
really sad place to be but you know no
one really cares right and that's sad
even worse is lots of people care right
you know something goes wrong your boss
shouts at you somebody loses money you
know something bad happens not quite
sure which side of the screen I want to
be on but you know we've got a line
right you know so it's no one cares pain
and suffering at one end so this is a
standard process so we've got a data
scientist who's also an exra from
Downton Abbey and he's he likes doing
codes so he pushes straight to get
pushes straight in me and then he's got
some magical wand and Magic happens and
things H just sort of spring up
somewhere you know who knows how it
happens it's just you know no one really
cares it just sort of works is and this
is usually bad
but not always right you know my part of
the talk is not for you to walk away and
go this is what you must do part the
talk is it depends so I do this all the
time if I'm doing slides and quarter or
markdown I'm giving a talk once I just
want it and get I want it you know it
should be reproducible but I'm only
giving that talk once and it's okay to
do that right it's okay or you might be
getting started in a project you know
you're just sort of messing about and
you just want to get something up and
running gets quite a nice place if you
drop your laptop and your moving
computers that's okay right but
typically it's bad but there's a few
exceptions so maybe someone does care
right you're now feeling a little bit
more love right you can give yourself a
little hug so you've got someone care
and so I'm sort of thinking about you're
writing stuff and people use
it but if you break the code you don't
really care you don't say that bit Out
Loud by the way but if you break their
code not really your problem if it comes
down to it right you know you might say
oh I'm really sorry I I'll I'll
prioritize that but it's not the end of
the
world so you know what what should you
do here well I'm going to say you should
use branches right and you think you've
lied to us you've just said this is
terrible well no no no no no don't do
this right this is bad right okay I'll
rephrase that it's bad for most of the
stuff that we do and I'm going to say
for 99% because it's a good statistic
made literally in the SP of the moment
99% of the room doesn't need to do this
right would you know it's not
us keep it simple right you know you've
got the main branch you create a feature
you do some commits you merge it back
into the main feature
disappears you create a feature you
merge it back into main you create a
feature you merge it back into mean it's
called the gith Hub workflow right you
know it's nice and simple it's not that
hard it's nothing particularly fancy it
just sort of
works and so what I would suggest here
is you know well first of all you should
protect your main branch right so
protecting your main branch just means
you can't push to it right you know you
have to go through this branching and
people always sit here and Nod but when
it comes down to actually locking down I
mean Branch they don't like that but
that's a sid problem and then have some
basic continuous integration right so
continuous integration is when you push
something up to get so GI Hub or get lab
and a little computer in the sky does
some work for you right so it sort of
chugs away and if you pass all its tests
you hear nothing and if you don't pass
it sends you nasty messages saying you
failed and the sof of test could be does
your shiny app run I'm not talking about
100 unit test I'm just saying does it
run if you run run app will it actually
just run the app right nothing
particularly
fancy can you P build your package again
not going through cran but
just who can everyone's got a CI for
that that' be good but does your package
just sort of build right it's as simple
as that does your qu do compile right so
something relatively simple relatively
straightforward that just takes out a
little bit of pain and suffering away so
that's what say that so here a Lo down
to abig guy well he's now tries to push
to Main and he gets a very sad face so
he's not very happy now but you can make
a little Dev Branch so here and pretend
it's a little shiny app so I've made a
little drop down menu I push to a branch
and then if CI passes that's good it can
get mer into Main okay and when you're
doing this in GitHub and get lab you can
do things like uh if the CI passes it
automatically gets merged right you know
you can sort of do that sort of stuff so
you don't have to sort of go to get Hub
and then start clicking lots of buttons
because if you're clicking lots of
buttons we're probably doing it wrong
but you can set it up so you can
actually push from the command line it
creates that Branch it runs the CI if
the CI passes it automatically emerges
and everything just disappears so you're
sort of still that nice simple step but
you've got that safety net of not
shooting yourself and then digging a big
hole for yourself and then throwing it
in head first you know you're a bit more
safe so let's suppose you know we're
getting a bit more important so we've
got a larger team right so you may have
two three four five people so there's
more than one developer and we're
wanting to keep track of who and
what and we're also so I used to work in
Academia and we you know I used to work
with a professor writing a paper and we
used to use git and his idea of using
git would he would phone me and say I'm
about to do some commits and then he
would hang up the phone and he would
commit he was more senior to me so you
just have to agree H you know like yes
okay uh so that was a a get workflow was
a phone call no not recommending that
workflow in case anyone's not paying
attention don't do the phoning part uh
whatever works so keeping track of who
and what so there's a Code owner file
right this is a really simple idea and I
think you know all well lots of your
your get repo should have it so it's a
very Simple Text file GitHub and gitlab
understand this natively right so that
means that GitHub actually understands
what this file does and means and all
that sort of thing you basically create
a little file called GitHub Cod owners
you just Google
it and it looks something like this you
know so star just means the group notes
admin so that be a group of users can do
what they want right they can merge join
and all that sort of stuff and this
person am's also got those
superpowers then we've got another
directory you know so website might be a
directory inside my get repo and website
admins and Tim is only allowed to to
change that website but they're not
allowed to change other stuff okay
there's few more options but keep it
simple and this is great because now we
can start locking down this workflow and
also if you're working in a team so we
deal a lot with with governments and and
those sorts of organizations where
people move around
teams because this is a file it's a
programmatic file you can now write
queries such as
what what get repos does Tim involved in
so Tim is moving from organization a to
over here so before Tim leaves we say
Tim what what repos do you involved in
we've now got a programmatic way of
pulling that information out and then we
can rearrange responsibilities and
that's
nice and so essentially we've got
exactly the same workflow except we've
got code owners who who are the people
doing the merging part not that hard
quite
simple next one so we're moving along
this line scheduled CI so you've got
your CI up and running so scheduled CI
hopefully you can figure this part out
it's a CI that's scheduled
uh so what we do is we've got a whole
bunch of internal R packages probably
like most of the people here and they're
built once a month right it's on the
10th and I've got them scheduled from to
run from sometime between mid night and
8:00 so when things break you just get
all these random messages through the
this period of 8 hours and so we' got
internal R packages any errors are sent
to a slack channel right so everything
passes so some ones not a problem other
ones things start start to fail you know
there might been a problem with L lentar
you know might been had an upgrade right
so in the 10th of every month we get all
these checks and then crucially we we
assign someone at jumping rivers to fix
that we give them actual time and their
workload you know we say 3 hours a month
you've got to fix anything that comes up
some months not a problem you know they
don't have anything so don't know what
to do go to Pub or something H other
months it's a bit more painful but
there's that time where things are just
sort of kept
routine also a useful thing is when
something breaks we then have to think
about do we care about this or should we
just get rid of this stuff it's very
good for doing Legacy software you know
if something breaks and you actually
have to fix a Sil thing you think a lot
more carefully of does anyone actually
use it do I really care about this or
could I just archive it right so that's
also just a nice way especially I think
in many organizations it's quite easy to
create this stuff and you know you look
at your back and you just got stuff
everywhere it keeps you
honest right next thing so we're moving
on continuous deployment so tends to go
along with continuous integration so
here what I'm wanting is I've created a
new
feature and when I create that new
feature and push that to get I want
something deployed without me having to
press buttons I want magic to
happen Okay so what I'm meaning here is
we've got this setup as before code
owner can't push to main when I push
this this new uh drop down menu to my
app I automatically create or
automatically launch that shiny app with
that new feature right so I'm pushing to
the branch I've created this branch and
the shiny app is automatically created
for me and then that means that my
wonderful code owner can then go in can
review the code and can also start
clicking on things in my shiny app right
you're taking that little bit of effort
away from them and then if everything
passes the code on is Happy it passes a
CI
then it would automatically deploy onto
the production server right so no one is
having to press deploy go move forward
and then when I've merged that that the
dev app would just sort of magically
disappear without anyone having to worry
about
it this part starting to take a bit more
infrastructure this part star to take a
bit more maintenance doing a code own
this file is dead easy right it's 10
minutes of Googling five minutes of
writing this stuff you know having to
think about well you're launching a sh
not for example it's going to connect or
it's going to wherever you want and then
you have to try and destroy it when that
branch is inmed so it does get a little
bit more tricky but it's a really nice
workflow and that's you know that's what
we do internally so it works really
well the last part and I'm just going to
just sort of lump this into sort of
pedantic
CI okay and this is just sort of
wherever you want to go right
so full full honesty I did this one
first seven years ago and really annoyed
the whole company uh but that's a side
problem so a news file you know you
could have a little CI job that checks
as a news file formatted properly you
know does it have is it has it been
updated right so one of our CI jobs is
whenever you update the package it
checks that the package version has been
updated right so you've made a change to
the package so the version must be
updated otherwise installed. packages
just breaks so it checks that and it
goes well if you've updated the version
number have you updated the news file
because it's really to forget this stuff
it's a little CI job that just checks
this it checks as a description tidy as
well does other things like our our file
names lower
case you could H we could do some stuff
in commit messages talk about later but
the world your oyster right you know you
could start thinking about actually
we've got 50% unit test coverage if you
make any changes it must be at least 50%
or greater unit test you know you're not
allowed to degrade that experience you
know so you can start adding on all
these
uh hops to go
through this stuff here starts to make
it hard to in board team members onto
right so all this stuff will say well
you can't just get someone in jumping
through you know to to start doing
commits because you've got all this
stuff to sort of make things proper but
it depends where you are in that line
right you know if you're making software
that if it breaks and lots of people are
going to be upset then well that's what
you have to do because you don't want a
mistake so you know it's where on that
line
something you know so commit lint uh
that's not an our package by the way so
if you Google it uh it's a it's an
additional add-on essentially whenever
you do a commit it checks your commit
message it follows particular standards
right so the first part for example we
have a bunch of key words so it might be
chore fix feature CI docs you know those
sorts of words if you do anything other
than those words you'll get a little shy
message then it'll do some stuff in the
right right hand side so does it start
with a capital letter is it too long is
it too short so again it does that this
can be really annoying right this works
well when you've got this mythical place
which I always live in where you your
your first commit just
works because your first commit you do
I'm feature you know adding in new Dev
uh new drop down menu but then you've
got the another 15 commits after that in
order to fix a thing that didn't quite
work and so I tend to then write fix
bump fix bump and then you're into
rebasing and all that sort of stuff so
it can be really annoying but it can
also be
useful I really do mean it can be really
annoying right so just to summarize so
if you're at the far left and it's only
you who cares right basically you know
use something simple get stuff done
right but then as you sort of make your
way along and you know people are
actually using your software and that
could be future you in a year's time
right I hate P me he's a complete right
then you want to start thinking about
protecting men adding in CI thinking
about code owners if there more than one
person thinking about scheduled CI
schedule CI again five minute job to set
up right you stick in a slack hook or
stick in an email not that hard you know
once you've got that quite easy not so
much fun when you get 15 slack messages
telling you all your packages are broken
but side point continuous deployment
absolutely wonderful but that's not a
5-minute job that also with think you
know experience takes maintenance it's
not a sort of you just do it and then
you walk away because you're deploying
it to a server and there authentication
and credentials and stuff right this
stuff there worthwh but there stuff and
then after that you can just you know go
where you want so I think we can trust
Jenny Brian so so that's good uh I I'm
safe not so sure she's write about set
WD if I'm perfectly honest you know so
she got quite strong opinions in set
working direct so I'll think about that
for next year but thank you very much
for listening and I hope you find
[Applause]
enjoy thank you so much Colin um we do
have time for a little question so
um I do find that it is easiest to
maintain good G uh um ways in life if
there are multiple people working on a
project I opposite but oh
well yeah I I I find it hard to uh to to
be my own uh like um bus when it comes
to that is there any like good ways when
you're alone to like keep keep the
momentum going there so what so
something I didn't touch on is you can
start templating this stuff so rather
than constantly adding little GitHub
yamamo files with your your CI part your
Git laab yamos You can put it in one
place and essentially temp plate it all
the way through so then when you're
setting up this stuff you essentially
sort of pointing say use this stuff over
here so then your CI you know you have a
very simple CI file which is just use
stuff over there and then essentially
the computer is a person keeping you on
the straight and narrow because the
computer will say no you're not allowed
to push no matter how you much you swear
at the computer fantastic from the botm
of heart do you like
good I do I but that's because everybody
else is using it wrong now it's just
yeah
but yeah I do but it's taken so long to
understand what's going on you know it's
taking a lot of time fantastic thank you
Colin
[Applause]
thanks